MARTIN OMANDER: Hello.
My name is Martin
Omander, and I welcome you
to Google Root Access, the show
featuring actionable startup
advice.
My guest today is
Mani Doraisamy,
founder of the
startup Guesswork.
Welcome on the show, Mani.
MANI DORAISAMY:
Thank you, Martin.
MARTIN OMANDER: So tell me a bit
about your startup, Guesswork.
What do you do?
MANI DORAISAMY: We are a
machine learning startup
that helps to qualify leads and
increase customer conversion.
We do that by building
predictive intelligence in CRM.
MARTIN OMANDER: Predictive
intelligence in CRM.
OK.
How come you decided
to focus on that?
MANI DORAISAMY: We
found this problem
that the leads from
internet marketing
don't convert into
customers very well.
Take this example of
real estate agents.
They get like 100
leads every day.
But out of the 100
leads, 90 of them
are from internet, from
Trulia, Zillow, and AdWords.
Only 10 of them are from the
traditional marketing channels.
But the problem is, out of the
90 leads, only five of them
convert into real customers.
But on the other hand,
if you take the ten leads
from the traditional channels,
the same five gets converted.
So business owners,
most of the time,
think that internet marketing
doesn't work very well for them
and start ignoring those leads.
We found that you could
use machine learning
and find out which
are the ones that
are serious inquiries
and casual inquiries,
and we could surface them on
CRM so that the small business
owners can focus on
the serious ones rather
than the casual ones.
MARTIN OMANDER: I see.
So you are taking those 90
and finding the gold in them,
finding the five there.
MANI DORAISAMY: Exactly.
Yes, that's the one that
increased, doubles the sales.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Doubles them, right.
You don't want to
discard the 90,
but you want to find the five.
So strikes me as a little
bit of trying to find
the needle in the haystack.
How do you find those
good leads in there?
MANI DORAISAMY: So when a
new user comes into the CRM,
we find out the
tone of the inquiry,
and we find out the
customer's social profile
and their interests
to figure out
whether there is a match between
the product that you sell
and the customer's interest.
But once the customer or the
lead starts engaging with you,
then you also have a lot more
information about the customer.
Like, for example,
what newsletter
clicks, what other
newsletter clicks,
and what's your subsequent
sales inquiries, and so on.
So that gives us a
lot more information
about how likely he's going
to convert into a customer
and when he's going to
convert into a customer.
And we accomplish
this by a combination
of the machine learning
algorithm and a rule engine.
So for machine
learning algorithm,
we obviously use
Google Prediction API.
And the rule engine is something
that we have build on our own,
and that's our [? IP ?].
MARTIN OMANDER: I see.
So tell me a bit
more about that.
I imagine when a new
customer comes onboard,
there isn't a lot
of training data
that the machine learning
algorithm can chew on.
MANI DORAISAMY: Exactly.
MARTIN OMANDER: How do you
deal with that situation?
MANI DORAISAMY: We
call it a cold start
problem in the machine
learning world.
I think that's one
significant problem
that all startups and small
and medium companies face.
That's one of the reasons
why machine learning has
been the forte of big
companies like Google.
Because Google has a lot of
data that it has collected
over time-- be it in search
or be it in Google Maps,
it's able to predict
how long it will
take to reach a
particular place,
because there is so much of
training data for the machine
learning algorithm
to predict it.
So what we have
done in our case is
we use a combination
of rule engine
so that we can predict
without the training data.
Take, for example, the
traditional CRM case.
So if a customer is replying
to your emails consistently,
then you know the probability
of conversion is more.
You don't have to use machine
learning to actually do
the text analytics to
find out what is the tone
or what is the interest.
So during using
the initial stages,
we use the rule engine to
determine the accuracy.
And once we start getting
training data that's
good enough to do
the prediction,
then it seamlessly switches to
the machine learning algorithm.
So it's a kind of handoff
that rule engine does
to the machine
learning algorithm,
and all this complexity is
hidden to the consumers.
MARTIN OMANDER: So
you provide a sort
of on ramp for the machine
learning algorithm,
but the customers
don't see anything.
They just see good
data coming out of it.
MANI DORAISAMY: Exactly.
And I think it's not just
a technology problem.
Some of these algorithms
work from day one,
because we focus on a
particular vertical.
We also collect data
about the social profile
and the interests,
and that gives us
the accuracy on the
machine learning algorithm
from day one for
certain algorithms.
And that also helps in
getting the algorithm working
from day one.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah, OK.
So then you have the
deterministic rules engine
working together with the
probabilistic machine learning.
MANI DORAISAMY: Exactly.
MARTIN OMANDER: So we
have here two types
of machine intelligence,
if we put it that way.
Is there any place for human
intuition in this equation?
MANI DORAISAMY: Yeah.
I think human
intuition is something
that we have been
relying on so long.
For example, if you
look at a sales person,
he looks at the
tone of the inquiry,
and he looks at
how many times he
has called in the last
week, and then his profile,
and then makes that
human judgment.
You can't completely ignore it.
So what we do is, whenever we
find that the machine learning
algorithms confidence
score is not that high--
it's like at 50-50--
then we ask the humans
to classify whether it is
a serious inquiry or not.
And that becomes a feedback
loop into the machine
learning algorithm.
So it's this combination
of the rule engine
that gives you the deterministic
algorithm that we have been
building for so
long and the machine
learning algorithm that is
coming up to the same speed
as the deterministic
algorithm, and then
bringing in that
human intuition, which
is the triangle
of the algorithms
that we think will be the future
of how machine learning will
evolve.
Because machine
learning is not going
to be this puristic,
single play algorithm.
It has to be combined
with the combination
of deterministic, probabilistic,
and human intuition
to be successful.
MARTIN OMANDER: And you weave
all of those into your product
and make good data
come out of it.
MANI DORAISAMY: It's
not just Guesswork.
We think that's how machine
learning will evolve
in the future as
well, because I think
that makes practical sense
rather than just being
puristic about the data signs.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
So let's get down to
brass tacks, then.
You've talked about
machine learning and rules
engine on a fairly high level.
What products or platforms
are you actually using
to actually make this happen?
MANI DORAISAMY: So obviously,
we use Google Prediction API
for the machine
learning algorithm.
In fact, from a machine
learning standpoint,
Google Prediction
API is the best
in the classification algorithm.
And as far as the app itself,
the one that customers
use to configure machine
learning algorithms
is concerned, that runs
on Google App Engine.
And we run the
rule engine on top
of Google App
Engine and BigData.
So for cases where you have
to transform customers'
data into the way the
machine learning requires,
we use vQuery.
So it does that ETL
job to transform
customers' data into
machine learning data.
So these are the three products
that we use internally.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
Well, thank you very much
for coming on the show, Mani,
and sharing your
experiences with us.
MANI DORAISAMY: Thank, Martin.
It's my pleasure.
MARTIN OMANDER: Thank
you for joining us.
See you next time.
We hope you found something
you can use in your startup.
Your input matters.
Please leave your
comments below.
We read everything you write.
To learn how Google
can help your startup,
go to
developers.google.com/startups.
If you would like to
be a guest on the show,
go to bit.ly/applyrootaccess.
That's it for now.
See you next time.